if we were to just triple and get to a
million this year would you be okay with
that all we're going to make you so much
money this is Ashley she runs a personal
styling business and my name is Alex
mosy and I own acquisition. comom which
is a portfolio of companies that makes
more money than I will ever need for the
rest of my life and so today Ashley will
be explaining to me her biggest business
challenges and I'm going to try to help
her scale her business $2 million in
revenue and beyond all right hi I'm
Ashley caps I'm founder of AC Styles so
we are a professional wardrobe and
personal styling service that helps
trans transform our clients confidence
and save some time so Revenue we make
about
309,000 annually
130,000 in profits that gives us about
42% in net margins so we've been in
business for about 4 years and so far
we've served over a th000 clients
thousand clients yeah how'd you get a
th000 in four years that's over my whole
uh career the business has been for
you've done a th000 yourself awesome
super cool so my immediate reaction was
she serves luxury clientele
and a lot of people who serve luxury
clientele don't charge enough because
they sell out of their own wallet rather
than out of the wallet of the person
they're serving or the value that
they're providing so that was something
that was in the back of my mind 42%
profit margin you know healthy a little
bit low given the fact that I figured
this was like a solar printer thing so I
was going to I be curious what the other
costs of the business were to make this
happen so who do you help right now
about 50/50 men and women typically in
their 40s all the way to their mid-60s
these are folks that are stay-at-home
moms they could be frequent flyers they
could be going up in their career into
the SE Suite those that really value
their time and really also value having
expertise so how do you help them we
transform our clients fashion style and
confidence and also help save them time
so we have two different phases in the
way that we do things so onboarding
phase phase one so we do a style
assessment so basically we establish
Baseline with their current style a low
style you look terrible like look at the
mirror you look horrible pretty much
okay we establish Baseline and then we
show them where they can go so once we
show them they can go that's when we go
in we gut the closet we get rid of
everything and we get them into some new
outfits looking feeling good and then
from there that's when we determine you
know just based on their lifestyle does
it make sense to work together on like a
monthly level on a quarterly level at
that point we know we have ongoing
styling sessions we put lookbooks
together okay cool and we have like an
on demand Service as well that they can
text us if like oh I goty if you will
pretty much so when you say you show
them what the future looks like is that
just like here's a like like looks of
like other models or something like that
or like putting together a style mood
board and then we also prior to that we
say hey just based on your complexion
here's the colors that are going to
complement you and then based on your
dimensions of your figure here's like
the Silhouettes that are going to work
best for you oh cool and then a big
component of it is lifestyle like what
are they doing on a day-to-day life and
making sure that whatever they buy fits
the life that they're living today and
not just like oh that looks really cool
on a mannequin got it initial reaction
seeing phase one and phase two that ashy
put together was good every quality
business has recurring or reoccurring
Revenue recurring means some sort of
membership or subscription reoccurring
is like Coca-Cola you buy some Coca-Cola
this month and next month even though
you're not on a subscription and so the
quality of a service or product is
dictated by the percentage of customers
that want to buy it again and again and
again the idea is that you want to
acquire a customer once and have them
pay you for the rest of their lives so
how do you make money important question
so onboarding package that I mentioned
8,500 bucks that's over the course of 60
days then it goes into either monthly at
2K a month or quarterly at 4500 a
quarter and then right now we also make
about 10% of our revenue from commission
from clothes we get about 10% margins
from the the vendors that we work with
Okay and right now we just actually
focused on having just this luxury tier
in the past we had two different tiers
and we focus more on one time and you
realize you make more money on the
luxury tier so you do more of that yeah
love it all right so that's what you
sell that's how you make money where do
you find them so right now we're doing
AdWords we're spending about 300 a month
with Google and then we're also spending
about 300 a month with Thumbtack we have
affiliates with other luxury like
services so like matchmakers and things
like that we host events and then also
of course client referrals do you know
what percentage of customers come from
each of this
uh roughly you don't know worries four
are coming from Affiliates I think about
a third is coming from the other two and
then a third is coming from refer so
kind of like evenly split between
referrals would you consider Affiliates
referrals or not no I kind of segment
those out okay so referrals is one
Affiliates is another then paid ads
between Thumbtack and Google yeah I like
to understand what percentage of
customers are coming from every source
so that I can see like is sometimes
there's one where it's like oh 90% of my
customers come from this and then when I
ask where they're allocating their time
it's like well I'm putting half my time
and this thing is getting me 10% of my
customers and then the other half my
time is getting me 90% it's like okay
well then let's double down on that
thing and the next following question is
like okay well is this Tapped Out is
this an exhausted Source or can we do
more and most times you can do more okay
so that's where you get them from how
many do you get a month so right now
we're looking at about 12 total leads
eight appointments 100% show for those
appointments total sales four so close
ratees 50% show ratees 100% 40 clients
currently and uh one churned in the last
year okay these 40 clients still pay you
monthly these are active yeah okay okay
so they're coming in from different
timelines so some are monthly some are
quarterly some are annually just from
different package testing we're going to
probably talk about that in a second the
40 clients thing because I think you
probably have a big Revenue opportunity
there so what's the goal right now all
right so you know just the easy five
million revenue and really I think what
we can do is because it's easy for me to
get stylists to train them is to build
like an education component just like a
totally different business I know yeah
but have Stylus in major metros okay so
have stylist in other metros and then
the long term is to be able to create a
training program for them like super
long term like super super long term
super super longm next lifetime oh I'm
just messing with you but fundamentally
for this business the goal is 5 million
doing what you currently do or a scaled
up version of what you do and in other
met major metros yeah yeah no that's
cool that makes sense 5 million big
number we can do it what's the problem
so what's what's what's holding you back
what's getting in the way leads okay we
need lead flow we need more of them
consistently and we just we need more at
bats that's really what it is and also I
haven't been able to be as consistent
with content creation and I think
there's opportunity Miss there for most
small business owners as long as the
core economics are good which a lot of
times they're not once you have the core
economics of the business you have your
price properly so you have enough gross
margin you have good stick rates and
people want to keep paying you over and
over again they come back they refer
their friends which actually has all of
these things then it's kind of Shifting
back to the front and saying we just got
to get way more leads in the door we got
to let more people know about it which
is going to come down to advertising all
right understand all that show me the
numbers so 309 in total revenue 130 in
profit 42% net margin Blended CAC of 600
um LTV is 10K annually so that gives us
a 16 to1 LTV to CAC ratio 600 in
marketing spend show ratees 100% close
ratees 50 okay got it from a basic
economic standpoint her business is
actually really healthy the fact that
she's only lost one customer over a year
out of 40 That's whatever 2 and a half%
turn annually is phenomenal the fact
that she has you know decent sh rates
and close rates all of that's good and
so me looking at these numbers shows me
that she's delivering some core value to
a key audience and honestly it's just
the N is low she just need to do way
more volume and then do you have any
other stuff by platform so Google we're
looking at 3,400 for the year for 2024
cost per click $189 total clicks 1,800
do you have prices on the site what do
when they click where they click does it
show your prices or is it just like an
opt-in page I do not show prices is
there a video that's being implemented
right now okay okay but I think that
that's the uh big problem is it's just
like he and you don't give them anything
right
there's no reason for them to opt in all
right we're going to make you so much
money it's a lot of fun so when I saw
1,800 Clicks in eight sales it was
clearly a conversion issue and so she's
leaking a huge amount of prospects who
aren't immediately ready to buy CU
that's all she has available is like
click you know click here schedule call
and basically buy and there's no
incentive and so I'm very interested to
see what we can do to solve that
conversion issue because it could be a
massive unlock for the business so
despite like basically no incentive for
someone to actually book a call you're
still making eight sales and so I think
that what's happening right now is that
like you the show up rate and the close
rates you have like you're just
basically skimming the absolute people
who are like are in such a dire pain and
they don't and you don't know them
because they're coming from ads right
right right like if you if you're in
that situation then like like this may
sound exciting for you but like you
could probably 5 to 10 x the sales of
the business just by fixing this like we
could do nothing else and you could just
do that so we'll get into that in a
second but okay the good news is that
even with the massive amount of
inefficiency that's there your ltbd CAC
is still really strong it's really good
and I think we're just losing we're just
leaking a lot in the in this process
okay show me the thumb tech one okay
also people that are in pain right now
CU they know that they're searching for
it so 6K total spend Leads Here 58 leads
38 bucks a lead total sales eight CAC
750 same LTV okay thing is thumb Tac is
like 90 to 95% unqualified in terms of
purchasing power M so it it's good
because it was a way for us to rank
higher for SEO through this page through
your thumb teac page that you then pay
extra to promote yeah on thumb teac okay
cool I mean 38 bucks at least not bad um
given the price point that you have but
the issues that they are unqualified so
do you actually do you have a minimum
income requirement I would say for this
new model a million a year in income
yeah okay so yeah so this is definitely
a top 1% 1% because 8,500 Plus
what is like it's about 25k all in for
the service the other the thing is they
have to have money for the clothes as
well so you're looking at about a 40 50k
let's just even say 25k year spend in
close Average Joe schok canot yeah I
love that Ashley is going after high
income earners I think a lot of business
owners are afraid to go after high
income earners and I'm very happy that
Ashley's already identified rather than
trying to say like I'm trying to come up
with this diet light really mini
versions she's just leaned into what
she's obviously really passionate about
about and just trying to find the
customers who can actually afford to do
the type of work that she wants to help
them with she doesn't compromise her
quality to meet lower-end customers and
I think that's really cool to be clear
I'm not saying that there's not a space
in the market for something like that
it's just obviously not her passion and
so she should stick to what she loves is
there a specific like life event or
something that happens that triggers
people into like getting getting into
this buying cycle yeah so it is
typically a a a transition moment I had
a baby my body has changed none of my
clothes fit that's for women I got
divorced both men and women or I'm just
I'm getting I want to start dating
period my image doesn't match my status
as a sea Lev person or even VP yeah so
that those
are those are the typical triggers okay
I feel triggered um no you're good okay
so that's the thumb D data tell me more
about the affiliate side the the the mat
because you've got I've got I get both
of these these I understand the referral
side I understand both your paid
acquisition Parts I think the continuity
is lacking we can work on that I think
there's efficiency ad funnel we'll talk
about that I think Affiliates is kind of
the last piece uh before we dive into
like figuring out what we're going to do
so for those you who don't know what an
affiliate is come closer I've got a book
$100 million leads and inside I'll I'll
read you the definition so Affiliates
are independent businesses that tell
Their audience to buy your stuff and so
Affiliates seem like referrals on the
outside but are actually much different
under the hood first they have their own
businesses and do their own advertising
second they agree to offer your stuff to
their engaged leads in exchange for
money free stuff or both both so she has
these Social Clubs and these matchmakers
that are existing businesses that
advertise their own services and she can
kind of harness those businesses to just
funnel some of their leads her way for
free now she has to do some sort of deal
with them to make it worth their while
but sometimes some businesses are like
oh you help my customers too and I don't
want to do that so here so basically
they we it's just like a lead pass
through so they make the introduction
and we offer a complimentary style
assessment to help help them get their
dating profiles ready it's really just a
glorified sales call okay yeah and so
you have these mat how many matchmakers
do you have who refer you customers on a
regular basis so combination of private
social club and matchmakers we have
about six okay how did you find them
Googling them and reaching you reach out
and did it that way mhm and what
percentage did they send you so as of
this year it's about a third ooh
M interesting
so when I see that she's got only six
people that are sending her a third of
her business and then when I asked how
she got them she just said oh I just
kind of like Googled them and reached
out I was like I had an inkling that she
had not done that much work to get a
third of her business that sounds like
onetime effort and then ongoing new
business like that's the type of high
leverage work that I love to see because
then each of these Affiliates become
consistent nodes of business for you so
even though the customers themselves may
or may not recur obviously she is is a
recurring Revenue model but the
Affiliates themselves become consistent
traffic sources where they send every
month one or two customers one or two
customers one or two customers and so
all we have to do is say how do we go
from 6 to 60 okay cool it's cuz it's
like very aligned audiences yeah they're
literally already buying the types of
services related to what you want it's
great I feel like I'm pretty clear on
what what he said okay yeah but if you
were to become an AC Styles client okay
here's an outfit you've got these really
nice Olive under tones dark features so
navies Browns these are your tones and
there it is in
action I like the we want to look like
the one on the right we actually look
like the one on the left you know what I
mean I could be Giga chat this could be
me thank you all I got no I appreciate
it this is good okay so you want to make
5 million right and we're at 300 so
that's a 17x from where you're currently
at right and so if we were to just
triple and get to a million this year
would you be okay with that totally down
cool cuz then going from a triple to a
5x from there it's like because the
thing is the business will usually
change there's there's something called
the Chinese rule of three and 10 which
fundamentally just means that sysems
break when they triple and so I like to
think in in triples in terms of unless
there's some massive order of magnitude
change that we can do but the things
that we have right now a handful of
these are triples independently and so
when put together I think we we
absolutely could get the five but I just
like setting goals and expectations kind
of kind of that way so that you're not
like oh my God I only made a million
dollars this year
poor me so Ashley's about to come over
to this side of the table and I'm going
to walk through a bunch of solutions I
think can help her grow our business but
before I do that comment below and would
love to see how you guys think and how
it compares to what we ultimately end up
doing all right that was awesome you did
great I've got some notes why don't you
sit over here and we'll gaml it out I
think what I want to do is break this
down in terms of who so let's talk about
the Avatar a little bit because then
that'll inform the offer and paid ad
stuff a little bit more to get it
targeted and then clean up the funnel
okay so first thing I want to talk about
is going to be the Avatar is getting it
on who you are going to serve cuz right
now you serve a lot of people not to say
that it's a bad thing but I think over
time we are going to get narrower so
that we can make our value proposition a
little bit more compelling for them the
next is going to be paid ads uh funnel
which we're going to look at the pages
and we're going to look at the offers so
that we can see okay can we tweak
something we add a lead magnet here that
would get the right people and word off
the bad ones and is there kind of some
process things that we can do that just
will stop the leakage the third piece is
still Acquisitions it'll be Affiliates
that I want to cover and then the fourth
uh what I want to hit on is uh
continuity and so those are the big four
that I want to hit on we can talk about
the corporate thing that you mentioned
in between my initial gut reaction is
not yet because the thing is is like if
we can get to a million probably we
could probably given the things that I
think that we're going to uncover here
you could probably get to like two is
two to three just from some of the
things I'm going to show you in a second
cool okay then maybe you get to there
you're at three you might be like wow
what if I just kept doing this rather
than the other thing um okay so Avatar
Clarity do you have any idea if there
are some customers that are like way
better than others or that you enjoy
enjoy working with more like what's your
dream customer and just like work
backwards from there stay-at-home mom
okay frequent traveler kids with many
social events mom who has kids with many
social events yeah okay like one
daughter just got married son is having
a baby that kind of thing so usually mom
so it's Mom right so there's kids
obviously cuz it's Mom okay got it
there's a few of these women plus money
got it and they just want to have new
outfits for all of their trip like
socials kind social lights private not
public people yeah yeah I understand
okay so Mom socialites is that the
number one your favorite Avatar and then
men
CEOs okay by percentage of Revenue is it
5050 yeah it is interesting okay CEO man
huh do you ever get cross cells CEO men
gets wife wife starts or husband starts
typically wife starts interesting this
is kudos to Ashley that she really
understands her Avatar and she
understands kind of the the part of
their life that they're going through
and what path to status they're seeking
to fill with her services and the reason
I was pushing on this is because
sometimes you'll find a business owner
who serves two type of customers hates
one loves the other and then still feels
like kind of beholden to keeping that
one that they don't like because maybe
it starts paying the bills and then also
the reason I asked for the split is this
as as silly as it sounds sometimes it's
like 30% of my business is this customer
I hate and 70% of the business is
customer I love and in those instances
it's like great get rid of those ones
and double down on these ones that you
love now she happens to love both and so
maybe in the future maybe at 3 million
maybe at 5 million a year I would maybe
look at this to revisit and say hey now
that we've had way more reps do one of
these customers stay longer are they
worth more some of these you know people
refer more than others but right now
given the data we have I don't want to
have her pick I'm cool with sticking
with both pay ads funnel can we pull up
her uh Google ads oh so they're not
running right now oh they're not running
right now okay do you know what page
they go to let's go to the work with us
page personal styling it's probably the
closest okay is it get more info if we
click that will that take us there no
Okay click on that though that takes us
to so right now they're filling out this
air table form that and then I send them
MH a kind of a brochure that breaks down
our services and then gets them to book
a call so that's a very simple funnel
all right and so this is them filling
out they basically check these boxes and
then scroll down okay so then we have
the contact First this is just a big
application yeah okay so first thing
that we can do on this one is is and
obviously this isn't I mean you could
okay there's a lot of things here but um
wherever you're driving your traffic to
so whether it's the homepage or it's
this page you should probably have some
big lead magnet that people are going to
want what's something that somebody like
that would want a lot so that's been my
thing after reading offers and thinking
about a lead magnet it's like what
appeals to these people and they don't
want to sit there and like get a
checklist of how to go through their
closet themselves so the only thing I
could think of and this isn't very
scalable is the complimentary style
assessment but that's one-on-one with
somebody mhm and that's okay though cuz
I mean you're still getting them to more
of them to opt in but right now is the
assessment the thing that they're
booking on the Google ads page today
it's just a a call okay so it's not
being positioned as as that so for like
the the 1.0 version is uh style
assessment is what you can basically
promise them uh on the landing page but
I was thinking more something like
really tactical like the perfect outfit
for you like one perfect outfit or
something to match their skin like like
your ideal colors like that would be a
cool one cuz like that doesn't you have
to like put a whole thing together it's
just like oh this skin cone you know
there's like 10 tones and you just pick
the one that's appropriate for them yeah
okay so we we're going to we were going
to do that next and and also something
else we were going to do the one perfect
outfit but it's it's so nuanced but then
we were thinking okay what if we just
share with them hey here's how B like
what are some of the steps that they do
to prepare to if if they were to work
with us how are they invested so we were
thinking like take their measurements
having them do some of these steps like
create uh creating a a mood board
themselves so we want them so for a lead
ma to be really valuable we want it to
be risk-free easy and fast and so those
things require effort okay and so we
don't want the Avatar to work to get the
value we want them to just click and get
the value okay and so I think what we
think about is like I like I think this
is actually really interesting this is
just me me personally so maybe I'm a CEO
man but it's like there are some some
skin tones that combination basically
it's like you have a combination of hair
and skin tone and eye color that is
unique to you and between all these
different permutations there's a hundred
different variations people can have and
they have a different color palette that
would be unique to them now you'll know
behind the scenes that there's probably
like eight different you know color
stylers or whatever and so I think
either doing color cuz that feels like
the easiest one degree more Nuance than
that would be a specific style being
like you know Street Wear hip-hop like
whatever you know what I'm saying like
you know that better than me
professional casual yeah exactly and so
I think that this is like you could do
this tomorrow you don't have to change
anything just by repositioning lead
magnet so the reason that I'm hitting so
hard on lead magnets and I have a whole
chapter about this inside the leads book
is lead Magnets How to engage your leads
is that she has this huge leak in her in
her funnel right 1,00 clicks and only
eight Sals so it's like we can solve
this with the right lead magnet now most
people give terrible lead magnets so so
a lot of people give no lead magnets the
the the few that do give lead magnets
often give terrible lead magnets and so
we want to have an exceptional lead
magnet which typically means we have to
work more on the front end so that our
Prospect has to work less and so it's
kind of like pre- digesting the food so
that they can just immediately get the
value think about you as a baby bird
just kind of feeding your prospects the
value and as a little Pro tip for you if
you have the choice between two lead
magnets one thing that's more valuable
but takes longer and the other is less
valuable but immediate this is the one
that customers will rather have
especially as a lead magnet which then
can lead to a service that looks more
like this I would experiment with the
different headlines there and then we
need to measure the conversion rate of
the page I know that you've turned them
down can you pull up the um the uh
numbers the interesting thing here is
like 1,00 clicks I think we could be
able to get somewhere in the
neighborhood of like if we're doing this
right like 500 leads from that amount of
spend oh and just if literally we just
need to nail this because on a Google ad
High intent search like
this you should be able to get like 30%
of people to op in so from a benchmark
perspective to this to something that is
right for this audience the only reason
we were able to identify this whole and
huge opportunity in Ashley's business is
because she actually had her data and so
it is amazing to me the amount of
business owners who have no data on
their business and they're like man I
don't know what to do well once you get
the data the data can often tell you
where your opportunities are and so here
there was a clear leak now she might not
know the benchmarks for this but having
been in the industry of business
typically an opt-in page for some sort
of lead magnet with qualified traffic
can get somewhere between 20 and 50
sometimes 60% of people to opt in for it
if it's very clearly defined and there's
a good match between the traffic that's
coming in and so for her me saying I
think 30% is a good Benchmark is kind of
where that came from like so if
someone's looking for personal stylus
near me or personal stylus La then it's
like what is the first piece and like I
always think about like our offer is
you've got all these steps that someone
has to take can I peel off the first one
even though it's something that I
normally charge for what's my actual
cost it's going to be time can I
template some of these things out so
that I can still provide a lot of value
but not have it take too much of my
personal time and the cool thing with
these um like kind of like more costly
or unscalable lead magnets is that you
only have to give it to people were
qualified so you are not obligated to
like you can choose to do this only if
someone who meets these qualifications
and you just say that in the landing
page okay so it's like hey if you're a
mom with kids and a social light or
you're a CEO guy and you're not getting
um what you want then like schedule one
of our style assessments where we'll go
through personally your skin tone your
hair color your eye color and find the
things that will immediately make you
look better just within your existing
closet cuz that's like again they don't
have to do anything and they'll
immediately look better that's like
immediate value not a lot of work okay
so i' be like okay that's what we're
going to offer so now I can get more
people to apply now they're going to
fill out their stuff and again if
they're not qualified it's like well you
didn't read the headlines so don't worry
about it and then for them I would
probably just send them some free things
so they feel you know they still gave
them something but that would be the
thing that I would do to improve the
funnel right off the bat without really
even seeing the funnel is clear headline
around what they're going to get sub
headline is either an image of like
almost like a before and after of style
or some sort of image that shows you
know white skin brown hair don't do this
okay and then they're like oh shoot I do
that and so just like a simple thing
that they're like shoot I do that and
then they're like oh my God I need help
and so all we're doing is increasing
deprivation so that they they take the
next action okay so that would be the
lead magnet component that I would do
for these paid ads now I think that you
have the scheduler so they they apply
then they schedule I know you're going
to put the video together yeah there's
the video before the call that gets them
to book and then I would probably
consider sending them a second video
between booking and showing okay and
then that does a little a little bit of
the pre-sale for you and I think about
this in terms of like what are those
things that you repeat on a regular
basis on the call so there's usually
like in every call there's kind of like
a little bit of a sales pitch that
occurs where you're like okay so let me
tell you about what we do I just try to
put as much of that before the call okay
so that I can spend the the majority of
the call on the person the
decision-making process rather than
basically have this like pre-recorded
script that I have to keep reading over
and over because it tires out you ties
out your sales team eventually and so I
would just I that's how I would I would
try to do it I think that if we can do
the lead magnet we can capture more
leads I think if we add the video to the
to the landing page so it would look
like this so we have our
page there we go we've got a little
video here and so then we have our
little scheduler underneath now this
Booker we should have our
qualifications so we want to have like
income right do you do you ask for
income no I would ask for income or
budget if you only knew two or three
things about them to make them qualified
what would you want to know are they
open to it's a good one okay uh open a
change yeah okay what about start date
yeah that too
okay the budget's really honestly the
biggest thing okay well then I would
definitely have that be prominently
featured do you think it makes sense to
put the pricing no on the no I don't
think so I think that if we ask for
qualifications and we describe the
services um that'll give us 80% and then
basically you just want to find cuz the
thing is is like you don't want to just
squ because there's some people who will
be in who have a smaller income but
really want this yeah and so it's
finding kind of that sweet spot which is
like if someone then says like I want to
start immediately I'm super open and
their budget's like medium then you
probably take the call right if they're
like my budget's zero then like okay
well it doesn't matter how muchad you
want it it's not going to work right so
two important points here one is that
when you give a very valuable lead
magnet away you don't have to give it
away to everyone and so we want to make
our lead magnet super valuable but only
give them to qualified customers and so
that's what makes it kind of like a
honey trap for the right type of people
number two is that what I'm going
through is baned which is budget
Authority need timing and so that's what
most people need in order to be
qualified to then you know get closed
and so asking those things kind of in
the friction process helps push out the
bad traffic and help us judge and score
the leads that are coming in so that we
can see which of these have the highest
leg of closing and then prioritize low
leads to sell and so I think that on
your qualification question which you'll
have on your scheduler we just asked for
the fewest amount of questions that are
required for us to make the decision
whether or not they should stay or not
okay all right so now we just have to
figure out and this is where like the
headline is like free you know look
better you know
dress for
your just obviously you know your uh
your your tone whatever and so this is
something that you will just test more
than anything else and it'll be relevant
to whatever your little freebie that
you're going to give them okay and I
like I really like the like existing
clothes so like how to best use your
existing closet I think is a really
strong angle because now they're going
to come in and then you're going to be
like oh you don't have one of these oh
you don't have one of these ah like and
then it's like and then it's then you're
like you're in the sale right so this is
probably what I would do for the Lander
and I think that if we did that that'll
give us more throughput that'll give
more leads in terms of followup you
currently don't really have followup
other than like manual hey checking in
kind of thing MH so if we want to have
the 2011 version of this we can take
this scheduler and put it here which is
like the thank you page and then just
make this an opt-in
where we just ask for this and then if
they're qualified they go here and if
they're unqualified they go like free
thing you just give them a free thing
that way you don't have to waste your
time and they don't they don't fill up
your calendar oh okay and that's like
with something different than the than
the either of these you're saying Yeah
okay or you do an automated version of
the same thing right right and so if we
wanted to to make it seem a little bit
more we could put
skin so like it it'll feel personalized
if you're like what's your skin cone
what's your hair color what's your eye
color that might be an easy thing that
you could ask and people like oh okay
this is personalized and so if they say
they have no money then it goes to the
here's what people who have brown hair
and white skin and whatever and then
they can just get that free thing and
then if they are qualified and have the
money it's like hey great all you got to
do is you know book your appointment
below and uh look forward to talking to
you and then you just work the lead
confirm the appointment just like you
normally would but then the lead is not
so much about okay so tell me about
where you're at with your style it's I
think you'll do that on the sales call
okay but I thought that with this skin
tone thing well we'll we'll deliver it
on the sales call delivered on the sales
call
right I'm just trying to think how that
would how do you how do you fit that
into the script so the way I would think
through this is that I'm going to have
like 10 templates that I know that are
color palettes that work for these 10
you know characteristic people and if I
have asked their skin hair whatever up
front then I know I'm going into the
call which template I'm going to be
using when I talk to them so it's like
hey oh you're blah blah blah actually
you know what I would describe you more
as Olive than white and I think this
might actually be a better thing for you
cool okay and then you go into your
normal sales process which obviously
works I don't I don't even want to talk
about sales SCH you're closing 50% okay
right now it's like book a cost a sales
call basically and that's like obvious
what I'm speaking about but then this
feels like oh just have a call about
skin tone well this is sales yeah and
then it it's not an issue because we're
they're already qualified MH you're only
taking the calls with people who have
the income so you're going to take more
calls you're also going to hear more
nose but you're going to make more money
like fundamentally I could I could just
say like I could run an that just said
hey I have this really expensive thing
book here if you want it and this is the
price and the people who h on those
calls will be incredibly qualified but
if I just said I have this really free
amazing thing that'll help you with the
first problem let me help you with that
and then people are like oh but do you
do any of ah you know what I do do that
stuff it's so funny you ask and I get 10
times the calls and so if I close 30% of
a 10x number I still close three times
the deals okay does that make sense and
so there's a little bit now part of it
is because you're selling out of your
own wallet in terms of time yeah and so
it's because you're like I I have my
time and I understand that but all we
have to do is just tweak these things so
like if you have somebody who you have
the information about them you have the
income and so what I try to do for these
is
band so budget this is kind of like the
um Authority can you make the decision
need how bad you want it which is your
biggest problem and then timing when do
you want to start if I were to accept
you when when you get started and so you
want somebody who says immediately I'm
in high need I can make the decision and
I have the money and so that's
fundamentally what these are and if you
want to add your personalization of like
skin and hair and what You' know this
better than me you know eyes upload your
photo yeah oh really yeah that one's
going to be a lot of friction so I would
consider having that in the Fallout
process okay because someone's like take
their phone out they got uploaded
pictures oh what because think about
this there's a decision they have to
make they're going be like what picture
am I going to pick and then it's and
then they're gone they're like in
another world and they're in their phone
and they're like oh yeah I forgot I have
to call Sandra back and then it's like
they're off I mean I can really just and
train somebody to just do it live yeah I
mean as many things as possible you can
do like we want to decrease the friction
here for qualified people right so
there's good friction bad friction so
good friction is something that
increases the overall quality of the
lead and gets out people who uh suck bad
friction gets everyone out a slow page
load time for example everyone leaves
good people and bad people we want to
get the type of friction that only bad
people leave and good people stay okay
and so if we have budget Authority need
timing we have the specific spe ific
things relative to the lead magnet then
your followup if you want like hey if
you can send me a picture it'd be great
if not I can just go off of your
Facebook profile or something like that
then they show up to the call you have
your one of 10 plates that you already
figured out ahead of time that then sets
up the sale which is for you it's like
oh you don't have this this this and
this all we're doing is expanding the
gap of like you're here you want to be
here oh you're missing all this stuff oh
you know what so funny I think you'd be
perfect fit for weh have can I tell you
about it and then you're in got it
makees sense yeah okay so this is what I
would do to change the paid ads funnel
can you spend more on this yeah well I'm
like dude if you if I had a machine in
front of me where you and this is
without you doing any of this that's the
crazy thing that's without you doing any
of this right so if I said okay um
instead of paying $3,400 uh a year what
if we paid like $3,400 a month yeah well
that would 12 x your business that'd be
chill right yeah I mean it beats the S&P
500 where you put a dollar in and get
$23 back within the next week it's not
bad right a lot of business owners are
scared to spend more money on marketing
because they don't have the data to show
what the return is if you have a machine
in front of you where you put a dollar
in and and it spits out $16 back in 30
days why would you have any kind of
limit on that budget you'd put as many
dollars in that machine as you possibly
could right of course and so she has one
of these machines and probably just in
preparation for this show uh she got the
LTV to CAC ready so she could see what a
discrepancy there was and if you don't
know what LTV toac is it's the lifetime
value of the customer relative to the
cost you acquiring them so basically how
much money does it cost me to get a
customer and then how much money do I
get from that customer once I got them
the cheaper it is to get a customer and
then the moreone money they give you the
greater the discrepancy between those
two numbers the more money potential
there is in the business and so this is
fundamentally the economic Arbitrage
that exists at the core of every
business that then fuels all the growth
of everything and here's the craziest
part Ashley is getting $23 back for
every $1 she puts into her machine and
she's only spending $3,400 per year in
this machine but that $3,400 times23 is
generating
$78,000 in income within a year like
imagine investing in the S&P 500 put
$3,400 in at the end of the year it's
78,000 you'd be like holy cow this is
the most amazing investment in my life
her business has that inside of it and
she's like hey I don't want to put too
much in I'm just G I'm pulling her chain
but a lot of businesses have these huge
treasure troves that are just sitting
there and not being leveraged I I'm
going to put an order of actions here so
I'm going to tear this off because and
we're going to save it and at the end
we're going to order everything okay so
the next thing um that I want to go over
is the Affiliates cuz I think that's
really important you would not touch
Facebook ads well you already have an
acquisition Channel that's working and
super profitable so I'm less likely to
want to do that now okay so um because
you can spend more if you wanted to yeah
yeah let spend more okay but we'll do
that I'll do actually put that as a note
for me so I'm going to put steps in here
for you okay um all right let's talk
about Affiliates so matchmakers yes okay
so you have six matchmakers right now uh
four matchmakers two private clubs okay
so I'll go I mean whatever it doesn't
matter yeah you're good okay so you got
six Affiliates yeah you've got four four
matchmakers and two private clubs okay
got it so how much time did it take you
to get each of these Affiliates not much
time
okay we did a cursory Google search of
LA and found that there were multiple
hundreds of the people who do this so in
a magic world what would it take for us
to go from 6 to
60 yeah I think not that long okay and
each of these sends you people on on a
consistent basis yeah what was the
process that you did integrate with them
I met with the owner and so you did
Outreach to get them manual Outreach
okay is it like phone calls text email
DM email okay manual Outreach um
explained that we can offer a
complimentary service to their new
clients oh cool and you know that we we
could close them love this almost like
it's directly out of the affiliate
section in the book wherever it is here
it is kly gutter sits in there all right
anyways keep going and that's and that's
and then they would and what percentage
do you close to the people that you talk
to um that's been the hard part is like
talking getting them okay do you know
how many Outreach attempts you did to
get to the six
um probably about
40 okay and I I want to I want to paint
something for cuz I think it's going to
be interesting okay it's not often that
you find you know a single point of
Leverage in a business that's as
clearcut as this one is for Ashley when
I do find them I get very excited about
it because it's like these are the
things that can change people's lives
right it can change the income they can
have the the the neighborhood they live
in the schools their their kids go to
and just completely can change a family
tree for generations and so when I find
these types of opportunities I just like
I I light up because I'm so excited
about it because I know what what's
going to happen I know what's going to
happen later once this lever gets really
pulled when she said that she'd only
emailed 40 people to generate a third of
her Revenue I'm like 40 emails because I
have a context of what kind of response
rates cold email gets and it's certainly
not you closing 15% of cold outbound
normally if you get 1% or half a percent
you're thrilled and so she's at like 10
times the efficiency 15 times the
efficiency of what normal outbound does
and so as soon as I saw that I was like
this is it so you sent 40 emails and you
were able to close Six right yeah okay
now how much money do those six so it's
a third of your Revenue right so it's
$100,000 a year roughly okay so think
about this so every one of these emails
need you
$2,500
yeah that feels like pretty good return
yeah for sending emails probably copy
and paste right
h two more of them what I have I have a
wild idea what if we sent 400 emails
yeah that's
it yeah if Ashley just goes from six to
60 Affiliates and they're currently a
third then that would be a 10x of
something that's 1/3 so that alone would
more than triple her business and here's
the crazy part what's the cost of
sending 400 emails it's even less than
the paid ads so her LTV a c on this
particular channel is even better than
her paid ad Channel which is already
insane I don't even want to mess with
the affiliate process that you have
right now yeah you're reaching out
manually is obviously effective you sent
out 40 emails like if you did that for 4
hours every day right that I mean you'd
probably be able to send even if you did
them completely personalized completely
manual the way that you probably did you
don't have to buy any software like you
can just send the emails you'd be able
to do that in like a
week or two weeks if you want to spread
it out it's like not a lot you know
we'll give you we'll give you we'll give
you the weekends off so we'll go so it's
40 emails a day 40 emails a day I'll
give it to you in a month how about that
so we'll do 20 emails a day 20 emails a
day that feels like that's that feels
reasonable yeah okay cool let's do that
best place to like pull the data good
question cuz I think it's the
matchmakers but it's also could be
executive coaches M could be um high-end
fitness trainers people going through a
transformation weight loss weight y they
need they need yeah for sure I would
think about about I think you have them
these in segments right and so you've
got high-end
trainers high-end pts number one you've
got exact coach right
mhm you've got the dating
people right yep you've got I'll give
you one divorce
[Music]
attorneys so that's four lists these
ones you can find probably from Google
this you can find also from search and
Instagram there's also like list Brokers
so you just like Google list broker
whatever City and then you can usually
they'll have this massive National list
and then you can W it it down to a a
localized area can you do any remote
Services yeah yeah we definitely I'd say
50% up like especially during covid we
only work virtually but I I prefer you
prefer in person that's fine that's cool
I like doing this stuff in person
because there's there's so much more
richness to the interaction I can see
someone's re I can see I can see minor
expression changes and I can gauge how
my you know recommendations like are
they confused by what I said or like are
they I can I can sense if they're like
not they don't want to push back cuz
they're like they don't want to insult
me or something like that I can see if
they like they don't really believe it
it's like okay I need to dive in here
more and make sure that like I can break
any belief that's here or maybe explain
something a little bit differently I
don't think I get as much of that online
or in like a zoom setting and honestly I
just like I mean I love business and I
think that when I have like kind of the
talking head videos which there's plenty
of on this channel I am a little bit
more intense in those settings because
I'm when I talk to a camera and there's
no one else there I'm basically talking
to myself and I talk to myself a little
bit more rough than I would talk to
somebody else and so I think in this
setting you can see that like I don't
like I'm Pro entrepreneur you know what
I mean like it doesn't matter whether
you're making $100,000 a year or you're
making $100 million a year like you're
in the game and for that you're
eternally somebody that I you have my
respect okay um so this obviously makes
money and doesn't require any Financial
Risk yeah and is also a compounding way
of acquiring customers because you did
this work think about this you sent 40
emails one time and then you got six
people to send you business for good not
bad now what do you do to continue to
reactivate them host events okay so you
do so you do events okay so for the
Affiliates yep okay cool um I mean like
especially for like the matchmakers
they're happy because their clients are
getting made over they get better
pictures therefore they get better
matches so I love that yeah really good
so I think uh do you do that like
regularly like it's on a calendar or is
just like okay good cuz that's obviously
that's why part of why it's working so
normally one of the things that that
falls off with Affiliates is that they
don't stay activated they don't keep
referring you and so you have to like
work them like customers like it's
another set of relationships but if you
can put them all together an event on a
regular Cadence where like all of the
dating coaches bring all of their people
and they all look good and they all get
to meet each other like that's value for
everybody it hasn't quite turned out
like that but just like more oneoff okay
like hosting events with the individual
company okay well still that works yeah
yeah and I think if you do like one or
two of those a year or three a year I
think that's like more than enough to
keep the activated and I would I would
try and figure out a way to put them in
the same room just because I think you'd
be like I would be pitching on
collaboration rather than competition
which is just like hey you have single
people so do they maybe they that's true
actually yeah they're all single yeah
they're all single and obviously looking
to mingle and trying to look at their
best life like um it would also be
desperation City but anyways uh so
that's so that's the affiliate piece
okay I I feel I feel really good about
that okay and so in terms of list I
would go list brokers
s social media and Google first that' be
like my first thing and then I would
look at list Brokers once I ran out of
those but between like these four
sources you need to send 400 emails it's
not that bad and then what's crazy is
like if you send it and then they don't
respond you could send it
again okay next one's continuity so
let's talk about that okay so this is
about increasing LTV right so you
already have pretty good LTV but I have
this feeling like there's something that
we can do better okay so right now
now LTV is
$10,000 right yeah okay so walk me
through so someone comes in so I come in
I'm CEO $88,500 I pay you for my whole
lookbook Etc transformation y okay and
so the delivery of that transformation
is like a lookbook primarily and then
like yeah walk me through it a little
more no so uh this assessment figureing
out where we're going to go with your
style your look then going through your
current closet right getting rid of all
the old stuff actually go to their house
yes okay get rid of all the old stuff
reorganize the closet so that it makes
it works for their life okay so closet
tear down yep and then we document we do
an inventory of everything in their
closet so that way when they text us or
they say hey I'm going to Turk St Kos
hey great pull this pull this pull this
uhhuh and we can give it to their um
housekeeper or whatever here's your
packing list okay then we get new
outfits new
clothes right now our promise is about 5
to 10 new outfits okay we don't want to
get the whole new wardrobe right but you
know enough to like okay I'm excited I
feel good mhm and then that's when we
make the determination okay does this
make sense given your lifestyle you
travel all the time on a monthly level
or accordly level yeah in terms of the
continuity you mean well do you have
turn on the continuity do a lot of
people so people stay and they keep
paying if it's in front of these people
not the one time people these people
they don't what was the one time thing
so it was priced at 3500 uhhuh and you
just did this but then didn't have
anything else yeah okay and it was um it
could be all virtually oh okay got it or
it could just be like a one day shopping
way better to do in person it's a
different relationship yeah yeah no I
like that I'm I'm I'm a fan okay so and
then the ongoing price point is what on
the back end uh 2K per month per month
or 4500 so LT so $88,500 and then
$22,000 per month so so we should be at
now I'm guessing that you have a lot of
grandfathered people of those 40
customers that are paying less yeah okay
what are they paying um 1,500
monthly yep week or per month month
okayo was like wow okay uh and then uh
some are on like 1500
quarterly okay got it got it I'm
guessing the majority of them are, 1500
quarter yeah okay got it because then
it's 500 bucks a month because this just
all transitioned in September we only
have like two people currently on the
new system okay so most people are at
$1,500 so if you have call 38 customers
who are at I'm just going to say in
general right $500 per month because
it's 1,500 per quarter I'm just looking
at Revenue yeah okay because this now
makes sense with the revenue that you're
doing okay cool so the vast majority of
the money is actually in a recurring
Revenue base MH that's not bad that's
good yeah that's really good and the
turn's low so all that stuff's good okay
so I actually don't really want to mess
with this that much because you have a
low turn what's the percentage of people
go from here to here now that I've just
said hey we're only working with you on
a reoccurring basis it's it's good right
um the thing is I'm almost wondering if
I did you say that yeah good I'm almost
wondering if we kill this and just do
the quarterly because this seems to be
not most people okay do you think that
it's better to simplify things or just
still keep it no I think you can have it
what happens it serves as a price anchor
okay so even if only 10% of people take
it it increases the people who take that
one okay so I don't think it's actually
a mistake that it's there okay cuz if
you're like cuz they had the reaction I
did I'm like $6,000 a quar I'm like
Jesus like or just do $1,500 like oh no
that works I'll do the $1,500 no no no
it's 2K a month or 4500 a quarter uh
with this one yes okay so you're saying
at the at the new price point yes it's
at this okay but this is brand new and
here you have all the retention that you
have so I dove into her continuity
because there's oftentimes a lot of
opportunity here in terms of billing
Cycles in terms of pricing in terms of
Ascension process to get more people to
go from front end to back end most of
her stuff here was working and I'm
trying to be mindful of the fact that
she's she's a very small business and
she has limited resources limited time
limited capital and so I want to be
really selective about the things that I
recommend that she do and in what order
so that we select the things that have
the highest likelihood of working that
have the lowest you know initial cost in
time and effort to make uh happen even
though I probably saw some opportunities
here that I think we could exploit later
for now I was like this is good enough
to scale we'll deal with it later once
we achieve more volume and then we'll
have more data that can make that can
inform our decisions even better and
most importantly we'll have the
resources in the cash flow to be able to
enact those changes without overwhelming
Ashley yeah yeah okay but you haven't
had any issue with sending people into
that into the $4,500 a quarter either I
mean the few that we've had no but it's
the same take rate yeah okay yeah so I'm
fine with quarterly billing okay so if
you have monthly and quarterly that's
fine okay I'm good with that yeah so
it's if it's now um 2K more SL 4500 per
quarter um but even if like 90% op into
this versus this oh that's fine totally
fine totally fine that's great no big
deal yeah all that I mean honestly we'll
just like I feel comfortable with that
but I always let the market tell me so
like I just keep edging up the price
until people stop saying yes and then
I'm like okay that's about right and
then and you kind of back down a little
bit and you're like that's my price now
I know that this for these for these
types of people that's the number that
they're willing to pay unless we change
the Avatar the marketing or the
messaging that's going to attract these
people and they're willing to say us at
that price okay okay so from a
continuity perspective I don't think we
Chang that cuz I think we just changed
it so that stays the way it is I think
the $8,500 I know LTV is $1,000 but
$8500 for the tail down and then you
have the quarterly and so this LTV that
you have here is probably going to go up
it'll just keep going up over time right
okay great so I mean honestly the so the
good news is the actual business is
strong okay so you have goodish margins
uh 42% continuity has almost no turn
that's great LTV CAC strong and so the
real leverage with this business is that
we just need to do more
all right so this is this is going to be
the priorities in terms of how we're
going to do this all right now you
stopped spending money on ads why cuz we
were adding the video and we were adding
in the you're fixing that stuff first
and then Okay cool so this is what we're
going to do so video sales
letter plus lead magnet
so plus the B qualification so budget
Authority need timing budget Authority
need timing plus skin
tone
color analysis personalization yeah yeah
Okay cool so that's number one so once
we fix that that's a that's a conversion
mechanism so then what I want you to do
is increase your ad
spend and So currently you're spending
600 was it $300 a month so why don't we
just go to
600 how much actually let me ask a
question how many can you handle like
how many more leads could you handle
than you currently are more like how
many more like that convert into new
clients yeah well like how many calls
basically it's a call thing so how many
calls can you take to turn customers
you're currently taking 12 right
something like that yeah easily could
double or triple that okay so let's go
with uh 600 to
900 per month cuz sometimes the lead
cost might go up a little bit that's
okay just like so basically you might
get a little bit less efficient but
that's fine cuz you're still you have
really strong TVD C so it's not a big
deal all right number three is we need
to send the 20
emails per
day to
Affiliates plus one
event per quarter to keep them activated
plus four affiliate
types that we went over all right so
this is a big three so the reason that I
put it in this order is that uh she was
already working on the video sales
letter and so it didn't need like I
wasn't really going to change anything
she was already doing so I was basically
like go put this in place and just add
the lead magnin which is really just
like you know you put a PDF together
it's an afternoon and you change the
headline on page it's not a huge lift
there increasing the ad spend is
literally clicking a button so the first
two things required basically no effort
maybe a half day of work maybe one day
total that could in of themselves double
triple the business then I was like okay
the next big lever which is the
affiliate play is to then let's 10x the
Affiliates that we have using the tried
and true Channel you already are doing
and just do way more of it but that
requires work and focus and effort she
has to Google the people she has to find
them then she has to reach out and she
has to personalize those responses and
so that's going to take more time and so
I wanted to just knock out quick wins
that she could just do with a click of a
button in a day before getting to the
kind of like the more mey things that
might take a few weeks and then I don't
want to mess with the continuity so
those are those are the like so if we're
looking at like how much could this do
it's like okay here we have a 2 to 3x
here actually I'm me to do this because
Michael will ask me to do this so we've
got a 2 to 3x here that we have from
this guy yeah I think this if I knew
what the conversion rate was on your
page so if you
sold can you go back to the um yeah okay
so here so we got eight sales this year
so it's like one like a little bit less
than one a month right so so I just wish
I knew how many leads were coming from
Google I just really wish I knew that
number and those eight sales were those
just like phone calls en closes so 16
calls created eight sales kind of thing
yeah okay so and they weren't from the
ads they were from
search got it but then they clicked on
your
ad you got I don't even know if they
clicked on the ad okay so we're also
going to do this before we put in the ad
spend so 1.5 so this is 1.5
we need to get attribution
tracking
okay because we have to know like the
first step of running ads is know what
happens otherwise you're just spending
money in the dark so obviously I think
you're you're getting a return by
accident rather than on purpose okay and
so let's get the attribution tracking in
place so this is going to
go we'll use
blue this will go up here all right so
you'll fix the funnel yeah you get the
attribution tracking in place I think
the funnel lift could very well like
this this this is going to sound wild
this could somewhere they R of like 2 to
5x the lead flow you
have just doing this especially with a
good lead magnet okay now the next piece
is that each of your Affiliates were a
third of your revenue and if we were to
10x that then we would 10x 1/3 which
would be a triple if we did
this and so the result of a called a 2X
to 2X and a 3X would be a
12x which would take us from
300K per year
to 3.6
million great we on our way excited yes
boom thank you now you bet you're going
to crush it so Ashley was amazing I'm
super stoked to see how this pans out
for her in the next 6 to 12 months and
you know see how her numbers uh go I'm
very bullish on it I think she's great
if you like this type of content of
actually diving into real business
owners real stories I personally loved
making this I prefer making this type of
content but if you guys like this tile
please let me know I'll probably end up
just making more anyways cuz I really
like it but either way let me know and
then it'll make me feel better about
making more of it for you